[Music]
this week on forward
economic development is fundamentally
about creating the conditions where
companies want to invest their capital
and people want to raise their families
the reality is that you really have to
treat the business as the customer and
go to the the CEO and go to the HR
department and say you know what what
does your demand signal look like for
workers what skills do you need what
kind of actually humans would you employ
exactly people want to have their
problem acknowledged and to be heard far
more than they want that problem to
actually be solved
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast my fellow forward national board
member president and CEO of Greater New
Orleans Inc one of the best guys I know
and that's saying something because I
know a lot of people Michael Hecht
welcome Michael
thank you Andrew it is a fantastic to be
here and it might just speak to the
quality of the people that you know but
I'll take it Michael and anyone
listening to this will see what I mean
because Michael spent his career uh
helping create opportunity and vitality
in New Orleans a city that has been in
the news for uh frankly kind of sad
reasons over the last decade or two uh
in terms of Katrina which we'll talk
about Michael
um but you did not grow up in New
Orleans I think you're a New York
product right New York educated by way
of New England and even uh the West
Coast yeah so you know we actually spent
some time in the same kind of neck of
the woods but you know my story is that
my family actually goes back to
Louisiana my maternal family goes back
to a little city called donasonville in
the 1830s they were economic immigrants
from from Europe
um my mother grew up in New Orleans but
she married a Yankee and so I was born
in New York City and grew up in White
Plains and you know you and I probably
did a lot of the similar things kind of
growing up and exploring the Upper East
Side yeah and and so how did you find
your way back to New Orleans after a
stint in business you graduated from
Stanford Business school and then worked
in a business out west which I I dare
say as a more customary conventional
thing to do out of Stanford uh rather
than spend uh decades rebuilding New
Orleans uh so first what was the West
Coast stint like after after business
school well you know so I mean it was
typical but it wasn't because at the
time I thought I was a contrarian but I
was actually probably a fool because you
know I graduated in 98 most of my
classmates were becoming like the
seventh employee at Yahoo literally and
I decided Well I'm going to go in the
other direction I'm going to go into
retail and I ended up building and
running restaurants in in San Francisco
during the first.com Boom and um you
know as a result a lot of my classmates
are retired now and I'm here in a hotel
room in in Lake Charles Louisiana
um you know so I ended up being an
entrepreneur building and running
restaurants uh one of them far in
Cinema's still going today 25 years
later
and I got to tell you that the the
experiences that I got from that
um learning to manage cash learning to
manage uh people
um learning what it's like to make
payroll
um those are all things that frankly
still inform you know me today and I
actually think that every young person
should have to
do a few things they just have to work
in a restaurant so they understand cash
and people they should have to do
military or do volunteers or Venture for
America to do service and they should
have to go on a Mormon Mission so they
have they can you know travel somewhere
and have to sell something that nobody
wants in a language that they don't
speak
to learn salesmanship but I I loved that
but what happened was we got out after
the um
dot com crash 2001 and my wife who is
Danish wanted to see the country
and I was thinking about this as I was
driving over today Andrew that I think
probably that experience was seminal to
me being come becoming involved with
with forward because we traded in our
hipster GTI for a pop top you know
Westphalia a camper
and when around America 15 000 miles
over over nine weeks and got to see just
the extraordinary beauty of this place
in in the Parks and in the people and
all this flyover country you just got
you know you develop an affinity for
this part of of America
um but it so happened we went through
New Orleans the ancestral Homeland and
Marlena my wife turned to me and she
said man you know we should move to New
Orleans it's the only place in America
you actually know where you are
and I said well honey that's because it
ain't America it's a northernmost City
in the Caribbean but
um regardless that kind of planted the
seed we ended up in Barbados for a
little while I was going to work for the
undp we ran out of money ended up in New
York City working for Bloomberg For
Mayor Bloomberg
um probably the most talented leader
I've ever really worked for uh doing
post 911 work for him and then when
Katrina hit folks from Louisiana came to
see us in New York wanted to see how we
were accessing HUD funds cdbg funds and
uh that's when I let drop that my
ancestral Homeland was uh Donaldsonville
Louisiana and um I made my way back so
what was the post Katrina experience
like uh you know having a major city six
feet underwater you know it was tragic
for all Americans to to witness but for
people who lived it'd be completely
different
yeah you know it was
um at first it was a surreal
um experience we had actually been in
New Orleans the weekend before Katrina
and
um as usual it was beautiful and you
know nobody knew anything terrible was
gonna happen I happened to during
Katrina to have been out at an
Australian friend's 40th birthday party
at Burning Man of all places so I
learned about it in the Reno Airport and
so in case I wasn't depressed enough
already I'm looking up on the screens
and seeing this
surreal Unthinkable disaster unfolding
um and it was a very strange and uh
disassociated feeling but then you know
I came back to New Orleans quickly
and um you know it was just as people
described all the cliches it was a war
zone it was um you know houses caked
with mud
um eight feet high I went to my college
roommate who had moved to New Orleans to
his home he had been a quarterback to
check it out and I found the the classic
black and white picture of him when he
was young and thin and had good knees in
his quarterback you know for Yale and I
found it stuck to the ceiling
of his living room
and I called him and I said you know
Tony what do you want me to do with this
thing do you know would you like it back
and he said Mike just just throw it out
we're moving on
but at the same time you know you began
to see these green shoots of of of of of
resilience
um you know homes with lights on uh
restaurants reopening actually last
night went to the first restaurant that
I went to post Katrina but I think the
most interesting phenomenon and my wife
comments on this a lot is that people
started a culture of flags they would
put Flags outside their homes a
fleur-de-lis or of American flags or
peace signs and I think they were using
these flags
um as symbols of of resilience and
resistance and just saying hey you know
we're home and you know we're we're
staking a flag we're coming back you
know by the time I started spending time
in New Orleans it was a number of years
later I started going down for Venture
for America in
2011. I went there every year for the
next six years so I have very fond
experiences brought my family down there
brought them to the zoo got stranded
there because there was no Uber service
out
so my wife was like what is going on I
was like oh don't worry honey it's all
out of
controls now I'm a very capable father
and husband
um and you arrived full-time uh you know
uh before then and have now become a
real pillar of the community so most
people uh when they hear the phrase
Economic Development
um they might not know what that means
or have some vague sense you have
essentially been Mr economic development
for a decade Plus in New Orleans and
anyone who knows anything about uh
frankly New Orleans institutions knows
you and your name like you yourself are
something of an institution in in New
Orleans in New Orleans now
um so how does one develop an economy
you know if if you ask my kids they'll
say that you you know make speeches and
send a lot of emails and go to cocktail
parties
um and that's frankly kind of what I
thought it used to be I used to think
that Economic Development was
essentially a sales process companies
would come in you would show them sites
you would take them to Ruth's Chris and
then you'd try to bribe them with
incentives
but what I came to understand from
looking at communities that were really
beginning to thrive
um like Austin like Nashville like
Charlotte
um more recently like Tampa
um
Asheville even Chattanooga I began to
realize that that actually wasn't what
true Economic Development was it's
really not about sales
economic development is fundamentally
about creating the conditions where
companies want to invest their capital
and people want to raise their families
and now post covid were remote workers
want to live and if you create those
conditions that are favorable to
investment and favorable to families
then the economic development is going
to happen organically and all your
challenges are going to be growth
challenges but if you don't have those
conditions because political conditions
are unstable or because quality of life
is not what it needs to be then you know
you can you know spend all the money you
want on on you know white burgundies and
on incentives and on you know meetings
with the governor and companies are just
not going to show up and certainly
remote workers are not going to show up
so economic development now uh the way
we Define it at gno Inc is to create a
thriving economy and an excellent
quality of life for everyone so there's
the wealth creation part but then
there's a quality of life part and the
third part about for everyone
it just simply is almost a mathematical
or economic truism that if you're not
optimizing the potential of all of your
citizens you're not optimizing your
economy so you have to be inclusive so
I've got a much kind of broader don't
color in the lines view of Economic
Development than I did 15 years ago
I am so pumped that the last election is
coming out September 12th the political
thriller by yours truly and Stephen
Marsh the author of the next civil war
will be in stores everywhere but you can
buy your copy right now at
andrewyang.com order now and be the
first on the Block to know how the next
election turns out it has all the twists
and turns will it be the last election
let's hope not andreang.com for the last
election buy it today thank you love you
all
[Music]
so when I became a.com entrepreneur in
the late 90s we started with a.com which
completely just flamed out immediately
and then I worked for another uh startup
that um raised Venture money and I I saw
I didn't understand at the time because
I was only in my 20s
um but we we raised maybe I don't know
um
seven million eight million dollars a
ton of money back then yeah but but it
was from people that really wanted to
grow grow so we were on this like grow
grow and the CEO to his credit probably
was like look
um we're either gonna hit a home run or
we uh just stop swinging like there is
no single double
um and that's because the investors had
that uh approach and risk profile and
it's just a certain type of company like
at the time I didn't understand it and I
uh frankly bristled at some of the
decisions we were making because I'm
like I don't know if that makes sense uh
but it probably does make sense in the
context of well you got to grow grow
um I've now seen that Venture model
break and kill like a number of company
companies
um and that company did not reach its
goals and then I became the CEO of what
I'd consider a normal business where
it's like you serve customers you make a
certain amount of money you hire people
you hire relatively normal humans you
have cash flow you have cash flow the
entire thing is cash flow like if you
don't make more in a particular month
than you spend than you're sunk and so
you do this thing called managing
payroll you have benefits you do morale
building
um and so I I ran that company for a
number of years and it was like the best
time in my life my wife still jokes
actually she's like when people ask me
my favorite time of my career I say oh
like you know running uh Manhattan prep
because I'd just be actually good in
rational and a good manager and like
that was the job as opposed to like some
of these other crazy positions I found
myself in where you're running for
president yeah when you're doing things
that are a little bit less uh clear
um but but because of that I
internalized this set of business uh
what I call business physics I suppose
and then you realize that and then you
realize that business physics has
stopped applying in a lot of segments of
the economy especially now with freaking
uh Ai and everything else like you know
I mean like all of our business physics
assumes that certain things have costs
and then now it's like hey it's
essentially free to you know like spit
out a million research reports but at
the end of the day though you know those
laws of physics ultimately come to bear
in some way
um and so for example you know in the
post-covet era when first Trump and then
Biden were giving out two thousand
dollar checks like like candy in order
to stimulate and then over stimulate the
economy
um I was looking at this and I was
hearing people say that oh you know it
was going to be fine and this was you
know kind of Keynesian stimulative type
of approach and that that there was
going to be a little bit of inflation
but it was going to be transitory I was
just running the math on that the math
on those physics and I said if we don't
have massive inflation then you know
Cartesian mathematics is broken so when
we had seven eight percent inflation of
course it was a challenge but to some
degree it was a relief because what it
meant is that the fundamentals still
actually apply and we're in such a
vertigious moment moment right now which
is has to do with where we are in a
historical cycle and Ai and I know you
had a guest a few weeks ago talked about
who is the professor talking about the
mathematical analysis of history and how
it says
yes I mean fascinating stuff and I think
that in these moments
um knowing that two plus two still
equals four gives us a sense of
grounding that we're not getting from
you know from the media for example so
um yeah there is something very
grounding about running a business and
making payroll and
um being a little bit old-fashioned
sometimes
I do want to press on that a little bit
um just in the sense that uh to the
extent we got inflation because of all
of the money printing most of the money
printing was not money to families I
mean like the child tax credit and the
rest of it was maybe 15 of the the five
trillion like you know 83 of it was uh
corporates and um and uh city and state
government some of which I agreed with
you know I mean you can't have some of
these uh like
um cities and states that can't print
money uh start hemorrhaging public
employees I mean that would have been
very very bad
so but we just we made a bunch of
choices you know but it's true that
producing the 5 trillion did spur
inflation and to be fair you know
thinking thinking about what we did or
didn't do after 2008 you know we learned
our lessons about being to our steer and
if we over correct it'd be probably over
corrected the right way right if you're
going to have one of the two a 2008
scenario versus having you know
inflation for a little while you know it
was probably the right mistake to make
or the right over correction to make
yeah I was in fire hose mode during Cove
and I was like look man just put the
fire out
um no though I I have a problem with the
way they directed the hoses but you know
like uh but but I had no problem with
the fire hose approach you know but you
know what I think the question is like I
think it's like if you think about going
back to you know the the depression and
the way we responded to that with things
like you know the Tennessee Valley
Authority and all the programs to get
Americans back to work and and to build
things that were of lasting value uh
lasting social projects I think one of
the concerns I have today is that we
don't have a Workforce that is prepared
we don't have enough qualified people to
do the work and the government
bureaucracy the government apparatus is
not really set up to to efficiently
process all of these funds and so you
know if you would say that we were going
to have
the five million you know dollars from
from arpa and IAH and all the other
fundings 5 trillion and that was going
to lead to these projects that we're
going to have lasting social and
economic value that's great but if it's
only was going to um if we don't have
the ability to process it or implement
it in ways that
um
Echo positively into the future
you know it maybe was still necessary
but there's less value we're not going
to be enjoying those lakes that were
produced that were made back in the you
know the late 30s as a result of um you
know the WPA dude I I think that's so
profound and it's one of the great
frustrations in American life that you
can speak to from experience
authoritatively because your
organization actually channels millions
of dollars to various things and people
actually wanted to like bear fruit and
bear results
um and one of the frustrations so many
Americans have right now is uh hey send
money and then the problem doesn't get
any better and then they're like oh you
know the problem is not enough money
send more money and then you're like uh
you know I'm not quite sure that's
actually going to do it and I'm going to
use an example that you know that this
that I happen to know the numbers on
um so let's say that your New York City
Schools uh and you're spending thirty
three thousand dollars per student per
year
um on on your school system and the
results aren't good and then people look
at it and be like wait a minute there
are 30 kids in a classroom it's a
million bucks like how was the teacher
getting paid like you know they're not
getting paid you know half a million or
a quarter million so you start looking
around being like what's going on and
then when someone says it's like you
know the problem like system needs more
money and then you're like wait a minute
I'm not sure that's right in my
experience and and I I think you'll
agree with this but tell me that the
issue is is rarely money and it's rarely
ideas because money is there if if you
have the political will to get it and
ideas are plentiful ideas frankly are
cheap it's it's it's
executional capacity right and and doing
and aligning incentives and when we
don't have the capacity to execute on
the dollars or incentives are perverted
which is kind of gets again back to the
basis of what we're trying to do with
forward then you're not going to get
you're not going to get good or
efficient results and so
um we spend a lot of time kind of
focusing on the money I think because
it's an easy or sexy ask but thinking
about
um incentives and implementation and
maintenance is not nearly as sexting and
it's much more kind of Technical and
pedantic but you know without that type
of approach we're not going to get good
results in our public education we're
not going to get good results in our
infrastructure you know or in our
political systems
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
if you're a regular listener you know
that I am a mattress guy and that I
believe investing in your mattress is
one of the smartest savviest things you
can do to be happier healthier more
energized more able to live your life
it's why I'm so pumped to recommend
Helix sleep because they are the
mattress company that will send a
customized mattress to you based upon
your sleep preferences risk-free made in
the USA number one mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine and there is a
special sale for Labor Day the best
discount I have ever seen them offer 25
off that's right Helix is offering 25
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners in honor of
Labor Day probably because a lot of you
are moving need a mattress go to
helixsleep.com Yang and use code Helix
partner 25. this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
yeah so I'd love to hear some of your
stories from uh greater New Orleans in
this because you actually have to figure
out it's like okay what can we actually
deliver on like we put this money in
place like what happens and so one
example that someone suggested to me
about
um let's say the transition to Green
energy it's like you put tax incentives
in place to convert it's like but you
actually don't have the trained
mechanics who are going to go out and
um uh and retrofit something or you know
change uh something to make it
um like capable of charging electric
vehicle or or whatnot so like the the
one of the big problems and this does
hearken to the change between
um let's say the recession era and now
where in the recession era the
government was like I guess we're gonna
freaking like take thousands and
thousands of Americans and we're gonna
dig some you know we're we're gonna
we're gonna make a damn do a bunch of
stuff
um and and now one of the the things
that Americans are getting very
frustrated by is like like you don't
feel like we have the operating capacity
and then if you do say like like if
America wanted to build a bullet train
in California as an example
um they'll just cut a massive check and
then you look back and be like what's
going on that train and it's like
that's a little experience right how
much have we spent on that bullet train
so far I think it's five billion and
right and it's like it's no nowhere
close to carrying a human anywhere yeah
I mean the so you know we we've had
um
a lot of experience that type of of
inefficiency and and actually
um a lot of it of my experience with
that goes back to working in New York
City you know uh under Mayor Bloomberg
where we ran some Workforce programs
post 911 that were where we have funded
and what we notice about them is that
they weren't getting good results for
companies or good results for workers
because the incentives weren't right
because basically these training
facilities were basically getting
getting checks for processing people
through their programs and there was no
accountability for the jobs they were
getting uh whether they were the right
skills they were getting and whether
they were sustained in those in those
jobs and so it was kind of uh it was it
was kind of a fraud the whole thing and
so what we've done at gno Inc is set up
a program called gnou and gnou kind of
flips the script because we said you
know although the workers who are trying
to help they're really not the customer
and although if you look at universities
academics want to dictate what they want
to teach or not to each because it's
what they did their PHD on they really
shouldn't be
um you know writing the rules we really
have to treat the business as the
customer
because there's this idea and I know
this from being a business owner as well
as being a fake politician as an
economic developer that there's this
concept amongst political leadership
that businesses are kind of like Pez
dispensers for jobs and if he does hit
them enough on the head they're going to
spit out jobs and you're going to be
able to take credit for them as as a
politician the reality is that you
really have to treat the business as the
customer and and go to the the CEO and
go to the HR department and say you know
what what does your demand signal look
like for workers what skills do you need
what kind of actually humans would you
employ
exactly and then you have to reverse
engineer from that back to the schools
back to the non-profits and then you
have to pipeline workers into that and
if you reverse integrate that way you
can actually create a sustainable
Pipeline and it ends up being kind of a
triple win because people are getting
real jobs workers are getting the people
I mean companies are getting the workers
they need to scale and the training
institutions now have Market relevant
curricula and so you know my favorite
example one we have on this is in a
field called mechatronics
um I'm really not sure what mechatronics
is but whenever I say it I think of
Fergalicious and ironically if you
Google the Fergalicious video they're
actually doing mechatronics in the video
it's all very very kind of um you know I
know it's the Multiverse anyway but for
this one
um mechatronics is basically next next
level assembly line work with computers
and robots and we are working with three
companies that do Advanced manufacturing
work then we're working with three local
two-year schools for training and
workers go and they are paid to go to
school then they go back and work on the
line and it's basically a German style
apprenticeship program and then when
they graduate they're hired and they're
making between sixty and seventy
thousand dollars and so this type of
program is what we're trying to
replicate amongst a number of Industries
including using international Partners
so
for example in Wind uh one of our
schools is working with a Norwegian
organization called Energy Innovation
that has embedded itself in the school
in Saint Bernard Parish most devastated
County in America by Katrina and is
training students how to work on
windmill blades which we're producing in
Louisiana so it's it's kind of an
obvious thing but treating the business
as a customer has helped us to create a
you know uh just a frankly a more robust
and serious and productive
um Workforce program so I tried to track
down the measured efficacy of
government-funded retraining programs
um for my book the war on normal people
and the best findings I could find were
between zero and fifteen percent and the
reports were that as soon as you said
hey we need to retrain these workers
someone would set up a diploma Mill uh
you know get paid to turn the workers
through and then shut down
literally this existed
government money and then like stamp
everyone's hand being like retrained
retrained retrained and then they would
disappear and then you'd have a legion
of retrained workers with value-less
skills like there was one story that so
this is a stupid thing but like my
editor actually took this line out of
the book
um because in the study uh there's a guy
who said something like my retraining
certificate didn't keep my wife from
leaving me
um it was
uh but so I put it in the
the boy editor just took it out as being
like a little bit too close to the Bone
um anyways but no that that's that's
what I saw and look I can take you to
that to that diploma Mill that I used to
work with at Hoyts Schermerhorn back in
Brooklyn and man when you figure that
out that what you thought is do
gooderism is really just the machine
um it's it's depressing and
I'd say I had a moment like that Andrew
and it's probably what kind of got me
here today so uh for a brief period
after we got out of the restaurant
business I figured it was probably
easier and probably kind of morally more
uplifting to give away food rather than
charge for it so I went and worked for
the food bank for New York City for
about two years great experience but the
day I quit was we were at this Gallum
and you know it was over at like on the
west side and there was Mario Batali
before he got in trouble and you know
Maggie jiggenhall and all these you know
actors and actresses and I was looking
at our brochure and on the back of our
brochure was this chart that had this
column chart that was getting higher and
higher obviously we were very proud of
this and I looked at it and what do you
think we were measuring that was going
higher and higher every year from the
food bank the budget of the food bank
basically it was the food they were
giving away right and so I'm looking at
this I'm saying guys wait a minute news
flash if we're an anti-hunger
organization I think we're I think we're
failing more every year we're you know
but then I realized oh maybe we're not
an anti-hunger organization maybe we're
just an income subsidization program
compensating for the lack of economic
Mobility for our working class in New
York City and I was like man I don't
want to be part of this I want to be
part of the solution I don't want to be
band-aiding this and I was out of there
within a couple of months
yeah it's one of the the tough
um things I I realized running a
non-profit that I'd started and ran for
six plus years that took me to New
Orleans in a bunch of other places
um was that a lot of the non-profits as
awesome as they are it's like damage
control uh and uh and in many ways it's
trying to fill gaps in bad uh
government programs bad policy
um so I mean I love non-profits
um one of the reasons though that I
ended up running for president was the
biggest nonprofits don't operate at the
right scale to solve the problems that
that I think you and I are animated by
which are society-wide so if you have a
25 trillion dollar economy
um and let's say in my vision of the
world it's like turning on more and more
people because of AI and technology and
a bunch of other things yeah the the
biggest non-profits you can find
um I I think the the literally the
biggest non-profit might operate in like
the hundreds of millions or billion like
you can't get to you know any bigger
number and that's probably the United
Way or something
I'm not trying to denigrate the food
bank the work that they do literally
keeps you know kids from starving on a
daily basis it's just that that's
charity and we shouldn't confuse that
with strategic philanthropy but it is
um it you know it feels like like we
really need to direct our attention and
this is you know there's there's a line
that again I kind of got this one from
my wife I want to give her credit for it
and that is that leadership is a
collective responsibility and so I think
you know we we rely on our elected
leaders to drive social systemic change
but I think that we have to recognize
that individually we actually have the
the opportunity to do that it might be
on one very specific issue but if we
take that issue and if we do the
drudgery of hitting it every day and
trying to change the policies and raise
awareness then you know actually
um we do have the ability to
to do one thing that's going to Echo
because it's it's it's systems change as
opposed to just helping a person it's
the old you know feed a man teach a man
to fish kind of deal
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
oh yeah you and I are attracted to
trying to solve the root structural
problems and create value I mean you're
an entrepreneur you know you you build
things uh like I consider myself the
same and so you naturally are like okay
like let's see what kind of problems we
can solve and there you know there's no
shortage of them
um I mean you've done so in a way that's
influenced uh you know at this point
probably like tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of lives
um uh in New Orleans and Beyond like in
in the region uh you know I I have been
trying to do the same since I started
adventure for America in 2011 so I guess
I've been at it for 12 years and it it
led me into the political realm because
I started to realize that number one the
biggest problems we have are unsolvable
without a functioning government
you know what I mean I mean like that
there's like a whole series of problems
we can solve with with commercial uh
applications and and uh companies that
are going to make money but then there's
this whole Suite of things that you kind
of need the government to have it
together
you kind of you kind of need government
to fix immigration right yeah that's a
fine example you know let's let's make a
short list just for fun I'm gonna say
you need government on immigration
AI climate change infrastructure safety
education
homelessness uh infrastructure you know
I'm up to seven or so and let me
actually give you another one which I
think is is is a little bit more
ephemeral but I think is incredibly
important and that is uh national
identity and Trust in institutions
because without that we get kind of back
to a hobbsian jungle pretty quickly
right and so you can't no wonder you
listen to that Peter turchin interview
Michael he's like oh we're like
approaching Hobson jungle territory
coming around the curve yeah so I think
that's why the work of forward and
everybody who's involved in this space
um is so is so important because
everything points to us going through a
period that's going to be politically
and technologically disruptive I mean
that that's that's a fact right and so
the question is if we're going to come
out the other side with a country that
we are proud of and where our kids and
grandkids can stay then I think there's
an imperative on those of us that are
lucky enough to have the ability to do
something to do it otherwise it's a
decade from now and you know uh and you
know we might not I might be in Denmark
you might be in Belize and I think
there's going to be a lot of sense of
regret because America is a young
country
um it's it's still an experiment and
it's it needs to still have people who
are interested in propelling it and
evolving it forward in a in a better way
um I want to dig into something you said
half jokingly at the top where you you
referenced working in a restaurant which
I totally agree with and my first job
was working as a busboy in a Chinese
restaurant uh and people were taken
aback by my perfect English because most
of the employees at that restaurant you
know we're getting busted from Chinatown
where are you from
well you know I mean I went to school
with their kids because it was my
hometown uh and um so a couple of busboy
stories randomly so number one I was a
busboy because my written Chinese wasn't
good enough to translate orders to the
kitchen which they needed in written
Chinese so it's like well I can't take
orders so I guess you're busing uh
number two everyone else would get a bus
from New York City's Chinatown to the
restaurant and then leave at the end of
the night
um and then I would get in my my you
know parents Honda Accord and just drive
up drive home individually be like yeah
bye everybody
um that three is that we would eat
uh leftovers from the the night
um like as a late night dinner
um sometimes that food was not great
because it was frankly the food that
didn't make that table uh and so I so my
my go-to was white rice with hot with
doused and hot and sour soup with uh the
fried noodles on top
hey you you were young and you're living
your best life yeah there were good
times so you definitely do learn about
service and people and money and just
the basics okay can I can I tell you the
most important lesson that I learned
about that from that which which really
saves my hide on a daily basis here it's
true story so our first chef was it was
a guy from Marseille and he was a very
talented chef but he smoked he chained
smoked Marlboro Red so he'd killed his
taste buds and um but he was you know he
was kind of a Marseille kind of you know
you know Sage poet De La Roux anyway
there's this one night and a woman gets
the bullion base and she calls me over
and she says
um I don't like my bully a base right
and so you know I said right on all
right well you know I'm I'm gonna I just
I copper the whole meal it costs us
whatever it costs us and you know and
they walk out and and you know and they
proceed to go and and just tear us apart
on Yelp or whatever people were on you
know back then Zagats or whatever
and so you know then the same kind of
thing happened a few a few weeks later
and just for some reason instead of just
comping the meal I went and I sat down
with her and I said
um you know I'm really sorry about your
bouillabase and I said it with a
straight face
um in.com San Francisco I said but you
know tell me what's wrong with me tell
me what you don't like about it so I can
get some feedback back to the kitchen
and we'll try to do better next time and
she proceeded to talk about how there
wasn't enough broth and you know that
and the shellfish were inadequate and
the toast was soggy and I gave her a
glass of wine and she proceeded actually
after that became one of our best
customers and what I took from that is
that people want to have their problem
acknowledged and to be heard far more
than they want that problem to actually
be solved so the worst thing that you
can do is to ignore somebody when
they're expressing uh distress about
something
um but if you go and say tell me about
your problem
you've then succeeded because you've
heard them and if you if you solve the
problem that's lanyap then you're truly
a hero but so now in this job when we
get hit by stuff every day my uh action
almost every time is to go right to the
source of the problem and say you know
I'm sorry tell me what's going on and
it's just that that is a restaurant
lesson that that I learned
um by copying a lot of meals that would
work very well in your current role it's
true that would that would uh um start
every conversation off on the right foot
so the the next suggestion you had was
something around national service uh and
um I put out on Twitter recently I said
hey what do you guys think about um and
I use the word mandatory which is a
strong word
um but I I said essentially required
national service I got a mixture of
opinions back no I'm generally Pro some
form of national service or volunteering
I I think it would be very helpful for
national identity I think that people
should feel like uh you know there's uh
an actual
um commitment and sacrifice and uh
um and privilege uh you know to to being
um a citizen and American and uh you
know like I'm the child of immigrants uh
and feel very grateful to have been born
here but one of the things that does
give me pause on it is uh is that and
this goes back to what we said before is
that
um there are a lot of young people now
please don't beat me up young people but
a lot of young people now who might not
be exactly like high value ad
contributors and a lot of
different environments and so you get
them in and one of the my my reference
points for this is that
um the military right now is having a
really hard time finding recruits that
don't have uh drug problems or uh some
you know like mental health problems or
the rest of it and there's something of
a mental health epidemic
um among young people and so you imagine
trying to take in
um you know 19 year olds and saying
right guys we're going to do this we're
going to do that and then you you might
find yourself in in all kinds of because
there's like this notion this
presumption that like oh this person can
tutor young kids this person can clean
up this person can like hang out with
old people
um or do something that's going to be
value-add even if it's not um military
in nature or Venture of America which is
entrepreneurial innate in nature which
as much as I love entrepreneurship I'm
certainly not someone who's going to
suggest hey like everyone should go out
and you know start a business or try and
solve a problem
um and and so it did get me thinking
it's like oh man especially in an age of
kind of struggly capacity which we have
it's like could this turn into like a
you know like a bit of a
um like a mess where you like bring
people in and then they they you know
like may or may not be doing the thing
that you need them to do
I don't think it's I don't think it's
easy to do and I think you're making a
really important Point people kind of
presume that getting into the military
is easy and kind of an option of Last
Resort it absolutely is not
um you know if you want an option of
last resort resort there are a couple of
bars in New Orleans I can introduce you
to so I think it is something that is
difficult and as you know from your own
experience you know managing volunteers
is really hard to do it very hard doing
it well like if you're going to do it
terribly then you know maybe you can do
that but if you're gonna try to do it
well and create value but I still
believe that if you if you if you define
national service broadly and so it might
be the military it might be it might be
working in a in a soup kitchen it might
be
um you know we're working in uh you know
in a facility for the elderly um it
might not necessarily be Teach for
America which for reasons Judo said can
get kind of fraught and and was kind of
a mixed success or even Teach for
America so Teach for America like
Venture for America I think they were
taking maybe one out of five Apple
applicants or something yeah yeah so you
know like it like there's there's a high
bar you know I think people look at that
and be like sure it makes sense I mean
you know it's a lot of responsibility uh
Venture for America was similar but I
guess you know what I struggle with here
what we're trying to answer is so um
when I'm in Denmark visiting my wife's
family you know you look at Denmark and
there are a lot of things that are
admirable about Denmark it's it's it's
it's a frustratingly competent uh and
cohesive country but it's also a country
where if you walk through the graveyard
there'll be about seven last names you
know it's an Anson Olson Anderson Jensen
and so there's a level homogeneity that
makes that you know cohesion pretty you
know pretty easy and it's a small
country
um but there is this uh and there is a
mandatory military service by the way
and you do get the sense that one of the
reasons why the country works so well
and frankly one of the reasons why it
always ranks as the happiest or second
happiest country on Earth and I can tell
you I promise you it's not because of
the weather is because there's a sense
of shared
identity responsibility
um there's trust in institutions and so
I think that if we don't try to push
back on the fragmentation
um that's being driven by it by social
media and by identity politics you know
we're going to give all that away and
you combine that with the way Trump
really pulled that at the fraying of the
social Fabric and
um again we kind of end up retreating
maybe it's maybe it's not a hobbsian
jungle but it's the default quadrant and
prisoners dilemma right where we're just
kind of protecting our own Empire of
dirt yep oh no again I'm very aligned um
and so one of the ideas I came up with
that was a hybrid when I was running for
president let me try it out on you
because it's like okay it's going to be
tough to get all these you know
um young people to do X or Y or Z but so
I was like so what is within bounds that
I think you could have the
infrastructure and it'd be executable
and so what I came up with was drum roll
please the American Exchange program
which was when you graduated from high
school you go to another part of the
country and live with a family that
frankly sending their kids somewhere
else and so then you you spend uh four
weeks in another environment where that
High School Community is taking in a
bunch of kids from elsewhere and then
they do a few community service projects
they meet kids from other parts of the
country I love that so much for for two
reasons that just come to mind one is
that obviously it's that experience that
changes everything you know it's it's
when we took our trip across America
it's when you visit another country I
mean it's when you when you deal with
people individually
um everything changes and as we know
statistically although the country is
more polarized than ever by political
identity when you ask people about
individual issues or values actually
there's really a clumping around the
middle so you know it would definitely
be be beneficial
in doing that the other one is uh so Raj
Chetty had this pretty fascinating work
that came out about a year ago where he
looked at economic mobility and the
thing to me the only thing that he could
figure out that mattered was not
education not even in in zip code per se
but Social Capital who you knew
and I'm kind of stretching this a little
bit but I guess the point is that what
that says I'm into it I mean if you had
like 10 Facebook friends from around the
country that you actually had spent time
with meaningfully uh changes even a few
weeks
the fact that you and I have spent
face-to-face time together means that
this is actually a meaningful
conversation that we're having if we
hadn't you know we I might as well be
swiping left or right you know with you
I would swipe right but I'm saying thank
you thank you thank you all of you right
swipers out there
oh you're you're Tinder Fuego but like
um so I think that that's actually a
profound
idea and um there's there's a program
here in New Orleans called Live Oak that
takes kids from different schools and
some of them are public some of them are
parochial some of them are fancy private
and just throws them in summer camp
together where they get mosquito bites
and like you know do dangerous sports
and I think that's probably one of the
profound social projects that we have
going that that's awesome my kids would
hate that
too
but I mean they would benefit
tremendously from it I mean they need
that really bad
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration on a flight most of the
time you'll probably be fine but what if
one day that weird yellow mask drops
down from overhead and you have no idea
what to do it's better to be safe than
sorry that's why I recommend using
expressvpn the network that's used by
high-end corporations for their remote
workers so that everything they do is
hacker proof Anonymous and verified I
like expressvpn because it's easy to use
one click and you're done and you can
access content that you might not be
able to see otherwise from Europe on
Netflix and other providers secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Yang that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang and you can get an extra
three months free
expressvpn.com yang
thank you
so you and I have now been working on
forward for a little while now you've
seen it all you've been inside of
government you've run major non-profit
organizations you've seen kind of like
the best of Institutions
um at work and probably the opposite of
the best in various ways
and and one thing I think you and I
share so that they're they're actually
so that like if you operate in a real
business like restaurant or
um you know my education company and
then you go around the country and you
have a sense as to how most Americans
live do you have this uh desire to kind
of champion folks who are uh
underdogs or overlooked in some way and
unfortunately now I feel like that
includes most Americans in most places
um certainly New Orleans I would
describe as something of uh like an
appealing Underdog uh you know having
spent time there
um and yeah yeah and and so the my my
question really is like what what are
the possibilities that excite and
animate you the most
um you you've described one which is
look you can actually create real
jobs if you actually use the
business as your customer and say what
do you need what kind of humans do I
need to provide your business such that
you will actually hire them now that
that's a harder thing to do than just
set up a government retraining shingle
and be like you know and frankly it's
harder to do at such high volumes I mean
I can give a gajillion workers a shitty
certificate and call it a day but if if
I go to if I go to the employers that
maybe they'll be like hey I need um you
know 50 people like this and then you're
like do you need 500 yeah it's a much
it's much more retail than wholesale
it's much more case management that's
right yeah yeah and and one of the
frustrations I have and I think most
people
um share at this point is that
everything seems oriented now towards
how something looks rather than how it
functions it's like if I can put out a
press release and never press conference
being like here's a big number and then
no one will ever follow up whether those
people in my front yard or send out a
snarky tweet you know then I'm a
slacktivist you know yeah yeah yeah and
meanwhile it's like if you track down
what happened to those like you know 5
000 retrained people and you have like
some abysmal success rate it's like that
you know like it doesn't matter people
have moved on I mean one of the darkest
things now is everyone is like all I
have to do is just hang on and then the
attention will move elsewhere and then
people will stop paying attention to my
oh there's there's a profound cynicism
that's right yeah because and and that's
and it's kind of what's creating this
epidemiological crisis because folks
know they can say anything and there
really ends up being no follow-up or
fact checking because then the next you
know thing has happened right the next
viral airplane video or whatever so my
so I'm actually going to double down on
that and then ask the question so here's
my doubling down where I ran for
president and was like hey guys you know
why
um all those Midwestern communities went
for Trump it's because we got rid of
four million manufacturing jobs uh
primarily due to Automation and all
those places went from blue or purple to
red and you know you can just look at
the data and then people and um people
would look at me and be like Oh
interesting interesting and uh and then
it hit me that no one would ever say
like wow 4 million that's a lot like if
we get to 8 million maybe we should do
something different like like I could
have said any number and it didn't
matter
um the substance of what I was saying
um just got filtered into like you know
a symbol I just became the math guy and
it's like hey math guy's saying some
interesting stuff but like the
underlying reality doesn't affect
anything
um in our uh policy making and if you
have that as your setup then we're
doomed because you know like as the
reality shifts in various ways and you
know why your idea is so brilliant
because if more of these people had
spent time in Ohio right or or Wisconsin
right you know they would have much more
empathy for what was going on I mean I
digress but I just want to say that's
why this this Exchange program this this
domestic Exchange program is brilliant
for that reason no who knows man maybe
Ford will will make it happen
um so my my question is
um so you're giving us one awesome
example I think most people will
understand about like genuine job
creation but what are the other
opportunities that you've seen and be
like okay guys here's something that we
can get excited about and build on I
guess the the setup for this this answer
is that pretty much you know every every
meeting or lunch I have it starts off
with how's it going you know one because
that's a good kind of small talk
question but two because people actually
think that I might have some sense of it
because Gino Inc is kind of like we
we're like that thing in the bottom of
the sink that catches all the food you
know we get little scraps of everything
so we have some sense
and what I tell people is that my days
these days in New Orleans are like
walking into one of those like you know
self-serve yogurt shops where you get
the swirl flavor you know in your cone
and one of the flavors I get every
morning is this beautiful swirl of
delicious creamy refreshing vanilla and
the other flavor that comes out in the
swirl is dog
and I used to try to lick around it and
it wasn't working and so now I get up
every day get the swirl cone take a big
bite wipe off my chin and take a swig of
the coffee and get to work New Orleans
today is a paradox
um I would argue
um happily with anybody that there's
more Economic Opportunity today than
even after Katrina with the billions of
dollars uh we're building a new two
billion dollar Port uh we're leading the
country on clean energy uh including
we're becoming the offshore wind
manufacturing hub for the East Coast we
are building the largest spaceship ever
built that's going to put the first
woman and person of color on the Moon by
2025 we're building the world's largest
windmill blade we're top 10 in the
country for women and African-Americans
in tech jobs we're building out what we
think will become the MD Anderson of
Alzheimer's a hub for Destination health
care for ages of diseases of Aging the
airport is at record numbers everything
that covet took away from us a culture
and connectedness and making bad life
decisions they're flocking to New
Orleans to to to re-experience those
things so on the surface or just looking
at that no New Orleans and frankly south
Louisiana is on the verge of a boom time
unprecedented in our lifetimes
but then going to the other side the
other flavor in the cone you get down to
kind of the the base layer of Maslow's
hierarchy
now blocking and tackling things around
Life Safety around infrastructure and
frankly around people's sense of of self
and self-efficacy and we're hurting
there
um you know 2019 before covid we were at
a 50-year low of homicides last year we
were at uh almost a record number a
total total reversal of Fortune totally
tragic that's awful tragic our
infrastructure is is old and and in
disrepair with the exception of the 15
billion dollar new wall we have around
us that helps with with hurricanes but
streets and and uh and flood water
drainage
um and then you get to this um you know
we talk a lot about the poverty in New
Orleans and and it's a challenge and
frankly the lack of a middle class and
really the black middle class which was
eviscerated by Katrina is a major
challenge but I think the bigger one is
that to some degree there's a Poverty of
imagination uh folks either have come to
accept uh some mediocrity or worse in
terms of basic services or frankly they
haven't spent time in places like like a
Nashville right now where things are
doing much better
and um without the imagination of what
we can become it's very difficult to put
pressure on political leaders to inspire
Civic engagement so New Orleans is a
very hot and cold strange place to be
doing business in right now because both
realities are too you know we're either
going straight to heaven or we're going
directly the other way well I need to
get back there as soon as I can I
certainly recommend hanging out in New
Orleans and making either good or not so
good life decisions uh you know whatever
you're there to do
it's a wonderful place
um if you do go to the zoo uh you know
make sure that the car service will
the zoo the zoo has excellent Daiquiris
which is another reason why to check on
the car service The Nightlife is great
the music's great the museums are great
the people are great uh I I've had a lot
of awesome times there I have been to
Jazz Fest and I've also spoken at uh
Collision which I think might not be in
New Orleans anymore uh Collision did so
well here that Toronto paid him two
million dollars and they went there but
they but we're we're restarting our
version of collision with some uh some
refugees from South by Southwest so stay
tuned on that that look at that that New
Orleans cannot be kept down you take
their conference they grow a new one
that's that the Spirit uh so Michael
people must have been bugging you to run
for office at various points uh you know
I mean you jokingly called yourself a
fake politician
um like what what do you project forward
uh uh and and I will say there are a lot
of people I know who
um at this point have almost become too
Savvy to run for public office I suspect
you might somehow be among that number
but
um if there's someone out there who
wants to follow your example make a
difference in their Community maybe
they're considering
um running for office they might not
know Economic Development exists as an
actual career
um like what what guidance might you
give to a young person who wants to
become the next Michael Hecht of their
Community well number one don't try this
at home because you know the my my you
know I've kind of reverse engineered
what I'm doing right now actually makes
sense of my previous you know 40 years
before these these 10 but um it was not
laid out and probably a thoughtful
enough way I feel very lucky to be here
but I think the key message is that
people have to understand are are one
um that if you pick an issue and if you
push the rock every day like Sisyphus
you will get it to the top you will make
a difference I have seen very few people
that put in the 10 000 hours that don't
make an impact but it's drudgery you
know it's not a tweet
um it's it's not um you know just doing
something performative it's it's kind of
an obsessive commitment that's that's
the the first um the first thing I think
the second thing is that I just want
everybody to be I know we're kind of a
broken record on this Andrew but it's
really one of the things I love about
you and the way you think you're such a
polymath but in everything that you're
doing you're always thinking about the
structural level of it and what leverage
can be pulled to drive systemic change
and so I would encourage any person who
wants to make a difference to try to
understand the meta story what is
actually creating the outcomes so don't
hate the player change the game
that's a way of
you know of thinking about about this
um and then I think just the third is
just to practice empathy to realize that
you know most people frankly want just
about the same thing they're just coming
at it from a different lived experience
and it might sound a little bit cliche
but if you can put yourself in their
shoes
you're not only going to understand them
better you're going to be more effective
in trying to drive the change that we
talked about in the the first couple of
uh elements well empathy indeed sounds
like an exchange program is needed
Michael Hecht thank you so much my
friend looking forward to trying to get
good policies across the Finish Line not
just in New Orleans but around the
country alongside you yeah Andrew thank
you so much it's an honor to be on the
podcast it's great to work with you
thank you for all of your leadership and
inspiration and yeah come back to New
Orleans soon I I describe New Orleans as
the most human city in the country maybe
the world
um you know it's it's not perfect but
boy it's it's a beautiful way to live
most human city is definitely a great
description uh I love it I'll be back in
no time yeah thanks so much really
appreciate you
foreign
[Music]